بافراد الامن المسؤولين عن
حمايته وهو ما كان. فهل يستمر
محاولة اغتيال عن كيفية النجاة
فنصحه بان يكون على علاقة وثيقة
سيناتور امريكي يدعو لمحاولة
اغتيال للرئيس الروسي فلاديمير
ذات مرة سأل بوتين فيديل كاسترو
الذي نجا من اكثر من خمسين
بوتين اثناء قيادته على طريق
سريع قرب سات بطرسبرج القناص ذو
الحظ العاثر. في عام الفين
وثمانية وعند خروجه للتمشي
عليه فورا. استهداف مركبته
مجددا. واخر محاولة اغتيال كانت
يقود سيارته كالمعتاد في الطريق
المحابي للكرملين لتصل بعدها مع
الخامسة كانت ايضا في العام
الفين واثنين. عندما كان بوتين
بوتين بنفس الطريقة عام الفين
وواحد. استهداف مركبته. المحاولة
المتآمرين. تلك محاولات اغتيال
الرئيس بوتين المعروفة وقد يكون
الرئيس الروسي انذاك ديميدري
ميدفيديف حاول قناص محترف
الطريق ولكن تم احباط تلك
المحاولة ايضا والقبض على
محاولة مشابهة تم احباطها في عام
الفين وثلاثة استهدفت مركبة
في عام الفين واثنين وقد تم
القبض عليه وعلى جميع المتآمرين
مرات عديدة عن كرهه الشديد له
والاغرب انه كان قد حاول اغتيال
يعاني من مرض عقلي وكان يصرح
دائما برغبته بقتل بوتين وعبر في
الشيشان وتخطيطه لتوفير
المتفجرات لاغتيال الرئيس بوتين
الاعلان عن اعتقال اربعة اشخاص
من الشيشان وعدد الاشخاص من
الشرق الاوسط والذين تورطوا في
محاولة الاغتيال هذه. استخدام
بوتين بذلك وتكون نهايته بموت
طبيعي ام ينجح اعدائه باغتياله؟
في العام الفين واثني عشر وكانت
تهدف الى تفجير مركبته على
الرابع. فكانت تتسم بالغرابة حيث
ترجل احد الاشخاص من سيارته
والحكم عليهم بالسجن لعشر سنوات.
شخص مريب. اما محاولة الاغتيال
يؤدون عملهم. انا اثق بهم ولا
اخاف. خلال حضوره قمة يلتا. اما
المحاولة الثانية فكانت في اغسطس
من العام ذاته اثناء مشاركة
محمل الجد. والا فان الامريكيين
يبحثون عن من قتل السيناتور هذا؟
بوتين اعتبر ان هذا السيناتور
يهرف بما لا يعرف ولم يحمل كلامه
هناك محاولات لم يعلن عنها.
فبوتين لا يفصح عن كل شيء. خرج
بوتين. وقال ان على العالم ان
يقتل بوتين لتنتهي حرب اوكرانيا.
ثلاثة اشهر من زيارة الرئيس
لباكو ازيري وذلك بعد ان وصلت
سانت بطرسبرغ وقالت السلطات
وقتها ان الشخص المسؤول عن
ولانه يملك حرسا شخصيا مرافقا تم
تدريبه على المستويات ويحملون
المتفجرات. وقد تم الاعلان عن
احباط محاولة اغتيال اخرى قبل
اغتياله ولكن لحسن حظ بوتين تم
التعرف على القناص مسبقا والقبض
المناهضة لبوتين كانت هذه
المحاولة الاولى لاغتيال بوتين
الطريق تستهدف بوتين نفسه ليقوم
بوتين بدوره بتغيير مساره وهناك
استخباراتية تفيد بوجود اربعين
كيلو جراما من المتفجرات على
الاول يعرف انه سيموت يوما ما.
وان جاء اجله فليس هناك فرق بين
الموت على ارض المعركة او في
حادث سيارة. لكن ما لن ما الذي
خصوصا وقد كثر الراغبون بقتله
بعد ازمة اوكران الحالي.
المواقف من قبل? رئيس اقوى الدول
في العالم اقوى جيوش العالم من
من قدر له الموت مشنوقا فلن يموت
غرقا. الله وحده يعلم كيف ومتى
وهو يدعي انه الرئيس الحقيقي
لروسيا بعد ذلك تبين ان شخص
وتوجه الى موظفي الامن في
الكرملين مطالبا بمقابلة بوتين
معلومات استخبارية تفيد بارتباط
شخص عراقي بافغانستان والثوار في
الاغتيال الاولى في فبراير عام
الفين عندما كان يحظر جنازة في
اغتيال الرئيس الروسي بوتين
اثناء حضوره جنازة. حدثت محاولة
هي ليست اي محاولات انها محاولات
اغتيال. ماذا? هل يعي هذا الرجل
ما الذي يقوله? ولماذا يقول زعيم
روسيا هكذا. هل سبق وتعرض لهذه
بوتين في قمة يلتا لدول
الكومنولث. وعقب انتهاء القمة تم
سيموت. هكذا قالها بوتين ولذلك
فهو لا يخاف من هذه المحاولات.
تعرض له بوتين ليقول ذلك. في هذا
الفيديو سنلخص لكم اشهر محاولات
الذي ستسول له نفسه قتله وهو
يعلم عاقبة مصارع روسيا وقائدها
احدث الاسلحة وادقها وقد قالها
بوتين يوما انا اؤدي عملي وهم
محاولة الاغتيال سليم عقليا
ولكنه ينتمي الى احدى المنظمات